voici une balance qui a beaucoup de tact
et ça c'est la partie utile d'un message
audio ce qui se passe dans ta tête quand
tu t'habilles le matin et ça c'est la
zone la plus acceptable pour une réunion
zoom dans ton salon ce qu on devrait
découvrir sur les tickets à gratter est
ce que vous devrez lire sur les flingues
avant de les acheter des dessins comme
ça je me suis amusé en faire des
centaines que j'ai recoupé dans un livre
qui s'appelle mes dessins et qui est
déjà dispo un cadeau idéal pour noël
c'est un bel objet collector qui se
partage autour d'un petit dîner d'un
petit verte a capté alors acheté le et
mettez le sous votre sapin moi je n'est
offert que ça à ma famille